a prayer for the Dead
and for those who survived Elias and
love who lost four family members after
a gas leak at this informal settlement
in boksburg near Johannesburg
the youngest of them two and four years
old
two other relatives are in hospital
I collapsed there in the corner they
took me and I drank milk when we came
back I found my sisters on the ground at
that point I felt dizzy I didn't know
what was going on I felt like I was
asleep
according to police the gas leak was
caused by miners illegally processing
gold just one or two breaths of a very
high concentration of nitrate oxide can
cause severe harm
police have confiscated at least 15 gas
cylinders tearing down shelters and
dismantling equipment as they comb the
area
there are several abandoned mine shafts
around here authorities suspect the
miners illegally use the gas to mine and
refine gold in formal settlements like
this one are poor dense and tightly
packed the gas quickly spread from this
area suffocating those around many of
them had no time to look for help with
at least six thousand abandoned mine
shafts there are thousands of miners
working illegally across South Africa
one month agoth miners working illegally
underground suffocated after a methane
gas explosion prevention and combating
of illegal mining it will never be a
sole responsibility of the police it
requires the role of government and
public sector to continue with it
several families in this community lost
loved ones we are 17 year old
doctor he only shakes his head
Al Jazeera boksburg South Africa